the Supreme Court is set to announce
some big decisions this week on
affirmative action and the Biden
administration's plan for student loan
forgiveness and the next round will be
released this morning which is why we
find our Major Garrett at the court for
us major good morning Good morning Tony
good morning everyone first affirmative
action two cases with the same basic
theme one challenges admissions policies
at Harvard University a private school
the other at the University of North
Carolina a public school now for decades
the Supreme Court has allowed race to be
considered as a factor in college
admissions the central question being
decided this time is should affirmative
action continue forever in the name of
diversity and are the gains achieved
worth the harms allegedly inflicted on
Asian Asian American students who assert
that these policies have unfairly denied
them admission in oral arguments the six
conservative justices on the court each
expressed reservations about continuing
to allow race as a factor in college
admissions the court will also decide
the fate of the president's student loan
forgiveness plan this this was put
together during covid the administration
argues that this forgiveness was
permissible under a 2003 law that law
gave the Secretary of Education power to
rewrite
student loan payment terms in times of a
National Emergency now the court has
heard forceful arguments that the court
should not Grant this Authority because
Congress never intended to give this or
any Administration such such sweeping
loan forgiveness Authority Vlad back to
you
all right major thank you very much